Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and there’s
a bunch of Marvel news lately mostly Ant-Man
and Doctor Strange but they just officially
said they’re not doing origin stories for
any new characters.
This video will mostly be about how that’s
going to affect the future of the Marvel Universe
but there is some cool info about the Doctor
Strange movie and Ant-Man started filming.
So I’ve got lots of cool behind the scenes
stuff to break down.
Starting with biggest stuff first No More
Origin Stories, Here’s what happened:
There are currently 30 comic book films from
all the studios being released between now
and 2020.
That’s 30 tent pole big budget movies in
6 years.
It’s totally crazy.
And if you look at the model Marvel, Warner
Brothers, Fox, Sony use for developing new
IP.
That’s intellectual property, meaning new
characters, dropping Origin Stories totally
makes sense.
Doctor Strange is the first Marvel movie that’s
going to adhere to this rule.
It’s not an industry thing, Marvel is the
only group that has said no more origin stories.
This is what used to happen when a studio
had a character or a team and wanted to start
a new franchise.
Like Avengers.
You have your origin story movie, then the
sequel with more villains, the another sequel
where the hero crashes and burns emotionally,
then a team up.
It’s a formula that almost every major comic
book movie has followed.
And it worked at first, but it’s been a
long time since Tim Burton’s Batman films
and the original spider-man trilogy.
Even since the first Iron Man movie.
Now the number of new characters is rising
exponentially.
Marvel, and I’m sure the other studios,
feel that people will get sick of the formula.
After 20 plus origin story movies, people
just won’t care as much anymore.
So in response, starting with Doctor Strange,
Marvel will no longer introduce new comic
book characters in Origin Stories.
What does that mean?
When we see the Doctor Strange movie, he’ll
already be Sorcerer Supreme at the beginning
of the movie.
Right now Doctor Strange has a director named
Scott Derrickson and a writer Jon Spaihts,
he’s the guy who wrote Prometheus for Ridley
Scott.
Here’s a quick history of that Movie at
Marvel.
They’ve had an in-house script for a long
time.
Marvel hires teams of writers to comb through
their catalog of characters and try to develop
scripts for characters that haven’t been
in the movies yet.
It’s an in house writing program they’ve
had for a while.
It’s how Guardians of the Galaxy turned
into a movie.
A writer inside the program named Nicole Perlman
thought that Guardians would make a good movie,
wrote a script, marvel liked that script so
much they sent that script to directors till
James Gunn accepted the offer.
He re-wrote the original script.
And the same thing is happening on the Doctor
Strange movie right now.
Scott Derrickson and the writer Jon Spaights
are re-writing the original script.
The old one was written to be an origin story.
Their new script they’re working on will
be more like the structure of Batman Begins
or Man of Steel.
It will still deal with origins, but only
in flashback.
Isn’t it funny to think that Marvel is taking
a cue from Christopher Nolan?
That’s not really going on, Batman Begins
is just a good example of a Movie that tells
an origin story without being a true origin
story in a linear way.
Even Guardians of the Galaxy already skipped
a lot of the characters origins.
You see Star-Lord as a child for about 5 minutes
before it picks up with him as a fully actualized
scoundrel slash hero.
Let me know what you guys think about this,
it’s huge thing for Marvel to say, no more
origin stories.
Do you think it’s better for them to just
pick right up with the action without first
seeing characters learn how to use their powers?
I think given the 30 films we’ve got coming
it will be a welcome change of pace.
And they can still do origin stories with
digital content.
That’s stuff that only gets released on
the web.
Or short stories they make and then release
as DVD bonus content.
Like the Marvel One Shots.
That original Doctor Strange script wasn’t
terrible.
It was written by the guy who wrote Sahara,
that Matthew McConaughey movie.
You can insert all the jokes you want.
But it featured Baron Mordo as the main villain
and followed the original comic book origin
story pretty faithfully.
There was an animated movie that did a version
of the origin story too with a few changes.
If you haven’t seen it, it’s as good as
Marvel’s other animated movies.
It’s streaming on Netflix Instant so you
can watch it there.
And you may have heard the rumors about the
bigger actors being considered for the movie.
They settled on one, but because that person
didn’t sign the contract before Comic Con,
they didn’t announce anything.
The biggest last minute rumors were Joaquin
Phoenix and Jared Leto.
Benedict Cumberbatch made some jokes during
his panel too.
He’d be my pick and he was in talks with
the studio.
But he’s doing Hamlet for most of the period
next year when they’d be filming the movie.
So I don’t think he’ll be Doctor Strange.
Picking someone like Joaquin Phoenix is another
good reason to ditch the origin story.
Doctor Strange is such a crazy character,
I could totally see him as this haunted sorcerer.
But I don’t think he’d work as well as
Stephen Strange the Doctor.
It’s also possible that the actor they want
hated the origin story script and that’s
part of what is holding things up.
Based on their release date they have to cast
someone and start filming by next year.
So they’ll have to find their man in the
next couple of months.
Speaking of shooting on to Ant-Man.
They just started filming this week in San
Francisco and released a picture, this is
a day one on the set picture.
Just to compare, the new Fantastic Four movie
has finished filming and hasn’t released
any images or promo art.
It shows Paul Rudd as Scott Lang in a van
down by the river.
The thought is that they changed the previous
script and are being more faithful to the
comic book origins.
The original script had him working at Hank
Pym’s company along with Yellow Jacket.
They explained some of the details in the
comic con panel.
I’ll link that video at the end of this
and in the description.
Now it seems like Scott Lang is going to be
a common criminal stealing stuff to pay for
his daughter’s medical bills.
He was always a brilliant scientist, he just
became a common criminal to help his family
survive.
He ended up stealing the Ant-Man costume and
eventually Hank Pym passed the torch.
I did a whole other video explaining the origin
of the character and how he ended up with
the avengers I’ll link in the description
too.
It’s pretty straight forward as an origin
story, he started in Avengers 181 in 1979
and officially took the mantle of Ant-Man
in Marvel Premiere 47 later that year.
So you should definitely check those comics
out.
He’s also featured in the 2012 Fantastic
Four comic Matt Fraction wrote.
That’s just a funny coincidence that I compared
the Fantastic Four reboot and Ant-Man’s
comparative open-ness with images from the
set.
I’d really love to see Paul Rudd in a future
Avengers movie, that probably won’t happen
during Avengers 2.
He was part of the team in the comics.
Maybe by the time they get around to Avengers
3 he’ll show up on the roster.
Marvel will be changing the Avengers roster
between Age of Ultron and the third movie.
Too many new characters will be around for
them to not include them.
And actors will start leaving.
I have no idea how long Samuel L Jackson and
Robert Downey Jr will stay with the studio,
but they are currently the senior members.
That’s a good question to end on, which
core Avenger do you think will be the first
to leave their role.
Like stop being their character in the movies?
My bet is still on Robert Downey Jr, he’s
currently only signed for one more movie and
that’s Avengers 3.
That was his new deal, Avengers 2 and 3 and
that’s it.
Unless they sign a new contract.
Since I haven’t done one in a long time
Tomorrow I’ll be doing a Marvel Q&A, so
feel free to ask any Marvel related questions.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ll post that first, then I’ve got a
new Arrow Season 3 Villains video.
They announced Komodo so I’ll explain him
and the other big season 3 villains.
Right now click here for the Q&A, I’ll add
the annotation as soon as I post it and click
here to learn more about the Marvel Inhumans
Movie.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!